Este martes se realiza la séptima cumbre
de la comunidad de Estados
latinoamericanos y del Caribe la celac
el encuentro que convoca a 33 jefes de
gobierno o sus ministros se realiza en
Buenos Aires Argentina y es la
oportunidad para concentrar a la
actualidad política de una región llena
de crisis de diversa índole política y
económica que pese a todo le apuesta a
la integración vamos al análisis con
María Villarreal ella es politóloga y
profesora de relaciones internacionales
de la universidad Federal rural de Río
de Janeiro María gracias a usted por
estar en directo a América
Hola Muchas gracias Es un placer estar
con ustedes vamos a empezar hablando de
El hombre del día el protagonismo de
Lula da Silva en la celac su
confirmación animó además la asistencia
por ejemplo de líderes como Díaz Canelo
como Nicolás Maduro el presidente
avalará el renovado protagonismo
mientras se defiende la invitación de
maduro y Díaz canel y sostiene una
posición entre China y Estados Unidos
Cuál será el papel protagónico de Lula
da Silva Sí bueno sin dudas Creo que
este es uno de los primeros momentos más
significativos de la diplomacia no
presidencial de Lula Esta es la primera
visita oficial que es una tradición que
se da aquí en Brasil desde los años 80
no la la primera visita presidencial se
realiza Argentina y bueno en esta
ocasión coincide con La séptima cúpula
de la celac no la séptima Cumbre perdón
de la celac no que es importante
recordar de que estamos hablando no
cuando hablamos de la celac estamos
hablando de la comunidad de Estados
latinoamericanos y caribeños que
organismo intergubernamental de ámbito
regional conformado por treinta y tres
países de América Latina y del Caribe No
con un importante papel en materia de
integración regional y desarrollo no
Brasil es uno de los países fundadores
en el 2010 que la celac empieza a
implementarse en el 2011 sin embargo en
el 2020 bolsonaro en el marco el
expresidente bolsonaro no en el marco de
una política de aislamiento no del país
retira a Brasil de la celac Entonces en
este contexto la visita de Lula se da
para retomar una agenda integracionista
retomar el protagonismo brasileño en las
relaciones internacionales algo clave y
además reincorporar no De hecho de
manera plena el país a este mecanismo de
integración entonces sin duda bueno Esto
es algo súper importante Lula ya lo
había anunciado en su discurso tras la
victoria en la toma de Posesión que
Brasil está de vuelta está de vuelta en
las relaciones internacionales está de
vuelta para bueno trabajar a de la
democratización de las relaciones
internacionales para trabajar por una
diplomacia activa y activa una
diplomacia que favorezca por supuesto la
integración regional entonces bueno Esto
es un ejemplo muy concreto de cómo vamos
a ver de ahora en adelante un Brasil muy
activo no con distintas agendas Bueno
pero es que además es un momento digamos
especial para esta cumple de la celac
porque la mayoría de líderes que asisten
representan un fuerte bloque de
izquierda como afectará esto los planes
de integración para la región bueno sin
duda será positivo los momentos de
convergencia ideológica son importantes
es Creo que vale la pena destacar que
claro Esta es una cumbre en la que hay
también bastantes divisiones estamos en
un nuevo ciclo progresista esto es
verdad pero es un momento muy complejo
para la región en su momento complejo
para Brasil por ejemplo que salió hace
poquito de un intento de golpe de estado
muy concreto no es un país bastante
polarizado muy dividido así como otros
países en la región es un momento
diferente es un nuevo ciclo progresista
sin duda Pero es un momento también de
fuertes divisiones no en este sentido
bueno Vale destacar que claramente se
extendieron las invitaciones a todos los
países que conforman América Latina y el
Caribe los treinta y tres miembros de la
celac cierto pero esto bueno no ha
estado digamos
no ha estado fuera no de críticas o sea
ha sido ampliamente criticado en la
medida de que bueno organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos organizaciones que
vienen trabajando No a favor de la
democratización han denunciado
claramente la visita o sea la invitación
la extensión de la invitación a los
representantes de Cuba Nicaragua y
Venezuela no a pesar de que algunos de
ellos al final no han asistido no en
este en esta celac hay varias ausencias
sí aunque 15 mandatarios han confirmado
su participación tenemos 33 delegaciones
Bueno hay algunas ausencias entre ellas
Nicolás Maduro Andrés Manuel López
Obrador Daniel Ortega Dina boluarte en
el caso de Perú Guillermo lasso Sí que
bueno son países que van a estar
representados por sus cancilleres sus
varias delegaciones pero son ausencias
importantes que
dejan muy clara también la división que
en este momento existe en la región no
la visita de maduro por ejemplo estaba
anunciada confirmada incluso sin embargo
fue suspendida el último momento tras
Bueno un conjunto de
manifestaciones que se dieron por parte
de la oposición Argentina miembros de la
diáspora venezolana incluso bueno
organizaciones como el foro argentino
para la democracia en la región fueron
muy enfáticos en denunciar la posible
visita de maduro Sí y bueno miembros de
la oposición como Patricia bullrich por
ejemplo hicieron una presentación ante
la DEA para pedir la captura de maduros
entonces me parece importante también
entender que estamos en un momento de
amplias divisiones también en la región
claro y este iba a ser la primera visita
de maduro a un extranjero en cinco años
entonces continúa digamos aislado el
presidente ahora quisiera preguntarle
por las múltiples crisis de América
Latina podríamos decir que estamos en
una etapa de inestabilidad política e
institucional incluso y le pongo
ejemplos Dina boluarte Llévame mes y
medio como presidenta en un país que
deja 62 muertos en disturbios el 8 de
enero seguidores bolsonaristas se toman
las instituciones de Brasilia en El
Salvador nayib bukele continúa
extendiendo su estado de emergencia ya
vamos 10 meses de esta llamada lucha
contra las pandillas y así podría
seguirle enumerando ejemplos de mucha
convulsión que se vive en nuestros
países de América Latina
a ver sin duda tenemos bueno hicimos una
región que digamos se caracteriza
históricamente por un conjunto de
convulsiones por amplia inestabilidad
pero creo que también es un momento de
oportunidades no es un momento creo que
la celac así como otros espacios se ha
hablado por ejemplo de relanzar la
unasur yo creo que más allá de las
contradicciones y es importante pedir
coherencia a los líderes que bueno
defienden la democracia por ejemplo es
esperable que en esta cumbre de la celac
se elabore un comunicado condenando los
actos golpistas contra la democracia
brasileña que se registraron
recientemente no en enero y bueno es
importante que Estos espacios también
sirvan para promover la democratización
de la región de forma más amplia
Entonces en este sentido yo creo que
incluso este nuevo ciclo progresista
puede ser importante para promover la
democratización de países como Venezuela
para impulsar transformaciones en
Nicaragua por supuesto en Cuba y también
para atender no que ellas demandas
urgentes como es el caso Perú con más de
60 muertos como usted acabo de enseñar
pues es algo muy ambicioso y solamente
el tiempo nos dirá hay otro tema que
llama la atención y es que Argentina
deja la presidencia protempore en esta
reunión de la celac que la había asumido
en enero del 2022 y esto después de la
cumbre celebrada en México sin que
hubiera consenso pero lo curioso es que
podría quedarse la celada sin una
candidatura firme después de la jornada
de hoy la única que fue presentada fue
la de San Vicente y Granadinas pero si
no logra el apoyo suficiente pues
entonces se quedaría volando la celac
Por qué la falta de candidatos
bueno es importante destacar que las
como foro intergubernamental no carácter
bueno evidentemente político toma sus
decisiones por consenso sí entonces la
el nombramiento de los representantes de
los presidentes protein por eso y de las
personas que trabajan en los distintos
grupos de trabajo Se da por consenso y
se da atendiendo criterios de carácter
geográfico y por supuesto acuerdos de
carácter político no entonces existe un
consenso previo sobre la posibilidad de
bueno ofrecer no representación en esta
ocasión a los países del Caribe a través
de El Primer Ministro de San Vicente Las
Granadinas que es González y que cuenta
con el apoyo político de algunos líderes
de la región no En caso de que no se
logre consenso bueno Es probable lo más
probable es que Argentina permanezca
dentro de sus funciones en la
presidencia Pro tempore por un tiempo
más hasta que se consenso se construya
no es importante destacar que claro
la celac no es el único foro no es el
único espacio donde se va a trabajar la
integración regional No aquí hay una
serie de disputas porque por un lado la
celac tiene este marco mucho más amplio
que es América Latina y el Caribe Sí
pero eh hemos visto en los últimos años
y también en los discursos de Lula Silva
que su diplomacia va a privilegiar sobre
todo América del Sur No de hecho Esta
visita especial Argentina en la que se
han dado bueno declaraciones conjuntas
se han firmado una serie de acuerdos en
materia de cooperación salud ciencia
tecnología se habló incluso de la
posible creación a futuro de una moneda
común para transacciones etcétera bueno
Esto denota un digamos el privilegiar
una región una subregión específica que
es América del Sur no Y esto se produce
en el marco también de un proceso en el
que se va a reactivar la unasur O por lo
menos está diciendo que se va a hacer Sí
entonces aquí también vemos algunas
disputas hay disputas de carácter
político Sí también de liderazgos en
relación a lo significan Estos espacios
de integración regional no Entonces es
probable que si no se logran
determinados acuerdos en la celac O si
la celac nos impulsa con una agenda
consensual no a nivel de los países
bueno habrán otros espacios que tomarán
protagonismo Y es probable que esa sea